If you don't know what to make for breakfast,
make this mixed Berry croissant bake.
It's absolutely delicious.
I start off by slicing my croissants
and layering them in a loaf pan,
putting the middles down first,
and then using the ends that I cut off
to fill in all the gaps.
Then I get started on my custard,
which is basically just heavy cream, eggs,
some orange zest and sugar,
cinnamon and vanilla.
I gave that a really good mix.
Make sure that all the eggs are incorporated.
Pour that over my croissants,
and then pop that in the oven,
wash my berries,
and then when the croissant bake was 80% done,
I pressed in my berries
and baked until it came out golden brown.
It was absolutely perfect.